[Music]
captured in the space of just a few
moments america at its patriotic best
and its bloody worst
an extraordinary volley of gunfire
filmed from multiple angles on the
phones of those who were at this
independence day parade to have fun
some run others for a moment think the
noise is part of the show
quickly realize this is yet another mass
shooting and this time it is their
neighborhood
the gunman had been firing from a
rooftop picking off his fellow americans
young and elderly
there was a young child there that
people i was doing a little cpr until
the paramedics got there and he looked
horribly injured i'm not sure exactly
the injury but i mean people were doing
anything they could it was just crazy
and i just heard i just remember hearing
people screaming and running
it took nearly eight hours for a manhunt
to end with this the arrest of a man
authorities say is a person of interest
robert e cremo the third known as bobby
is just 22. a search of his name online
has revealed a social media footprint
that will be vital for investigators
an amateur rapper with a fascination for
guns
videos that appear to depict mass murder
that suggests a dark troubled
personality
five people were confirmed to have died
at the scene
there's a slight moment of silence in
washington a moment of silence
the president's july 4th address was
hastily changed to reflect the news
you all heard what happened
we all heard what happened today
but each day we're reminded
there's nothing guaranteed about our
democracy
nothing guaranteed about our way of life
we have to fight for it defend it and
earn it by voting
all down this road the chairs the flags
the bits and pieces of an independence
day parade left behind
as people ran for cover this is a
community which began the day ready for
that all-american ritual of july the
fourth and it ended the day numb and
again with so many questions that gun
debate will go on and on
how did he get his weapon and where did
he get it could all this have been
prevented
schools churches supermarkets now a
community parade
another community shattered
just so depressing k as i said and when
we arrived here uh this evening in fact
having come from a a another
independence day parade in washington dc
these are things events that happen in
communities right across this country we
arrived at this one so similar to the
one that we were at and
it was just eerie awful as you saw um
empty
and all the paraphernalia of a family a
day out left there
in terms of the investigation will the
police have a person of interest as they
are describing him in custody he's a
local man you saw a little bit of his
social media presence
there in my report it will be a center
of their investigation what we don't yet
know of course is did he legally own the
weapon what sort of weapon was it how
did he get hold of it key questions that
the investigators will want to answer
and the american public not least here
in this community will want answers to
and fast